I'm loving this like American Pie
reunion meat but here's my question do
people still look up to you and say this
one time at Bank
yes they do what you lovely to be
associated with the movie people still
know but I have two daughters now and
when they're with me and they people
don't follow through hang the line I'm
like can we just stop there I'm not I
get really panicked well wait you have
kids like wait when it came out did your
kids see it no no my boy my daughter was
12 and so that that's a little early
that's that's a little early my son was
15 and he was going to come with us in
Los Angeles we went down for the
premiere of the movie and the night
before the premiere he he said he was on
the phone call with his friend back in
Toronto and they said well what's going
on he said well I'm going to the
premiere of American Pie tomorrow night
with my folks and the friend said oh
don't see it with your foe don't see it
with your folks don't want to see this
with your folks so he came to us and
said you know what I think I'm not gonna
go tomorrow and I'll see it when I go
back to Toronto with my friends and I
said I thought oh well okay it's gonna
be a big night meanwhile we went to the
premiere saw the movie I'm so glad he
wasn't
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going